bevor wir anfangen wie geht's ihnen ja
gut ich habe Urlaub von der Ostsee und
das Leben ist sommerlich schön übrigens
der von Ihnen genannte Titel Winter im
Sommer hat noch einen zweiten Teil ich
weiß Frühling im Herbst und da geht es
um 89 ja das ist ein älteres Buch danke
dass Sie ich liebe dieses zitiert habe
überhaupt nicht erwartet naja weil es
weil es weil es tatsächlich ein
interessanter Blick ist noch nicht
vielleicht darf ich das ausnahmsweise
mal sagen sie sind 83 sowieso heute
ist natürlich interessant von jemandem
zu hören der in einer Diktatur groß
geworden ist sie wie sie und der sagt
das war der sehnsuchts ziehen diese
Demokratie und dann war es diese
friedliche Revolution das haben wir
mitgestaltet wir sehen nachher ein
Ausschnitt aus einer ihrer reden wo sie
beschreiben was das für eine Euphorie
war ja und wir besieht man daran gegen
glaubte wir können jetzt die Welt auf
den Kopf stellen und heute sitzen sie da
mit ihren 83 und sagen ich mache mir
Sorgen um diese Demokratie sie zeigt
Schwächen
wissen sie hat eine Idee wir schauen uns
mal an
ihren Anfang als Bundespräsident ihre
ihre redet damals 2012 da gibt's ein
paar Sätze die haben es in sich wir
hören mal kurz rein
wir lassen uns unsere Demokratie nicht
wegnehmen wir stehen zu diesem Land
speziell zu unseren rechtsextremen
Verächtern der Demokratie sagen wir in
aller Deutlichkeit
euer Hass ist unser Ansporn wir lassen
unser Land nicht im Stich
wir schenken euch auch nicht unsere
Angst
ihr werdet Vergangenheit sein und unsere
Demokratie wird leben
[Applaus]
was geht hier durch den Kopf wenn sie
diese Worte heute hören ihr werdet
Vergangenheit sein ja die Vergangenheit
die wird noch ein bisschen auf sich
warten lassen ich habe
dazu gelernt seit dieser rede ich habe
damals so ein Traum von politischer
Wirkung und Gestaltung gehabt habe nur
die richtigen Worte und ein
menschenwürdiges anständiges Ziel und du
wirst alle Menschen gewinnen können und
schon bei meiner Arbeit am folgenbuch
über Toleranz bin ich auf Studien
gestoßen über die wir wahrscheinlich
heute noch reden werden die beschrieben
haben dass immer in jedem Land eine
bestimmte Gruppe der Bevölkerung so
gestrickt ist so geprägtes psychisch
dass sie stärker führungssucht und nicht
so sehr eigene Mitwirkung und
Mitbestimmung dass sie eher eine Autorin
Heeres Lebensprinzip bevorzugt und
Freiheit er problematisch ist und
Sicherheit
der eigentliches Hauptthema und das ist
mir in meiner Bedeutung in seiner
Bedeutung damals noch nicht bewusst
gewesen und deshalb müssen wir uns auf
eine längere Auseinandersetzung gerade
mit Rechtspopulisten einstellen als ich
das damals noch gehofft habe das
interessant weil sie das gerade sagen
gab kürzlich an der Studie die genau das
untersucht hat und wo es genau um diese
Themen ging und da zum Beispiel eine
Aussage die da lautet wir sollten einen
Führer haben der Deutschland zum Wohle
aller mit starker Hand regieren
ja und ja die volle Zustimmung bei 14%,
die teilweise Zustimmung über knapp 20
ja es gibt da noch viele heikle Fragen
in dieser Studie und die Studie belegt
insgesamt dass wir in diesem seit 30
Jahren wieder vereinigten Deutschland
immer noch zwei unterschiedliche
politische Kulturen haben
natürlich gibt es Anhänger von
nationalen populistischer Gesinnung auch
im Westen aber diese sehr starke
Rückbindung an autoritäres geführt
werden die es da und das lässt sich bei
jeder Wahl belegen es gibt ja Leute die
sagen wir sollen aufhören von Ossis und
Wessis zu sprechen ja kann man gerne tun
nur das Faktoren es gibt eben die so
Unterschiede das sind keine Konstrukte
sondern die sind an vielen Fällen unter
anderem eben im Wahlverhalten und auch
bei solchen Umfragen statistisch so
gründlich belegt das ist töricht ist an
diesen Unterschieden zu zweifeln nur
woher kommen die Unterschiede und da ist
es wichtig dass wir uns gerade in der
westdeutschen Mehrheitsgesellschaft klar
machen es sind keine Charakter Mängel
die die Ossis der Kollektiv haben also
Diktatur können alle wenn die Hessen und
Bayern 44 Jahre drauf gekriegt hätten
auf die 12 Jahre Nazi Diktatur dann
wären sie heute auch eine andere
Völkerschaft das heißt lange polit
Ohnmacht bleibt nicht ohne Folgen das
was die Demokratie uns erlaubt ein
Individuen freier Selbstbestimmung zu
sein und vor allen Dingen
Eigenverantwortung zu trainieren von der
Schule an das wird genau das Gegenteil
wird in der Diktatur gefordert Gehorsam
und Anpassung wie zu Zeiten der Fürsten
bringt dich nach oben und so ist es als
wären zwei Teile die eine
unterschiedliche Sportart trainieren und
die sind aber zusammengekommen sie haben
andere Lebensfelder andere
Trainingsfelder und natürlich ist ein
Großteil der Ossis nämlich die Mehrheit
super schnell aufgewacht hat diesen
Stress nach der Wiedervereinigung als
viele Lebensläufe nichts mehr wert waren
viele sich beruflich orientieren mussten
und arbeitslos waren die haben sich
durchgekämpft und durchgebissen und
wählen so ähnlich wie die Menschen in
Westdeutschland wählen aber eine Dinge
die für eine große Minderheit hat im
Grunde diesen
abschiedsprozess von dem alten nicht
abgeschlossen sie sind
in einem Zwischenreich sie fremdeln mit
dieser offenen Gesellschaft die ist ihr
zu vielfältig macht ihr Angst naja und
dann sucht man in Zeiten der Angst und
jetzt komme ich noch mal auf diese
Studien die ich eben kennengelernt habe
und die ich in dem Buch auch beschreibe
diese Menschen die so strukturiert sind
dass sie eine autoritäre Disposition in
ihrem Leben haben das klingt jetzt
schlimm ist aber nicht schlimm es ist
erstmal normal das sind Menschen die
Freiheit weniger lieben als Sicherheit
wie schon erwähnt aber die mögen auch
dass wir mehr gleich sind oder dass wir
mehr zusammen sind dies gefolgschafts
Problem das heißt das Maß an
Verunsicherung ist ungeheuer groß so
groß wie einige meinen noch nie in der
Weltgeschichte zuvor und in solchen
Phasen von Krise da haben oft die
traditionellen Parteien nicht die
größten Antworten und dann erscheinen da
welche am Rand unter ja wussten wir
schon immer das geht viel zu weit mit
der Moderne das ist alles Irrtum wir
wissen es besser und sie sprechen dann
so als würde man die Vergangenheit
wieder ins Leben rufen genau homogen
und dann erinnern Sie sich so wie die
Generation meiner Eltern nach dem Krieg
ja es war auch nicht alles schlecht beim
Führer ja also es war früher ja auch
nicht alles schlecht in der DDR nee war
es auch nicht es gab Frühling Sommer
Herbst und Winter und die Leute hatten
alle Arbeit ist auch ein Ergebnis dieser
sehr interessant
Hitler wäre ein großer Staatsmann
gewesen wenn er nicht die Juden
Vernichtung vorangetrieben hätte hätte
Zustimmung auch zum Teil bei um die 20%
auch in dieser Studie wann haben Sie
Herr Gauck um ins Hier und Jetzt zu
kommen wann haben sie zuversichtlich auf
dieses Land geblickt damals bei dieser
Rede beim Antritt oder heute nein ich
gucke heute noch zuversichtlich weil das
Land eben wenn wir die lange Perspektive
anschauen dann gibt's heute viel
Unzufriedenheit die Demokratie macht
Fehler menschen machen Fehler aber die
Summe der Fehler überwiegt nicht die
Summe der Möglichkeiten und der Erfolge
und das ist ganz zum Schluss meines
Buches komme ich darauf zurück nachdem
ich ausführlich über Erschütterungen
gesprochen habe die ich mir nicht
herbeigewünscht habe aber die mich ja
nun doch bewegen und dann habe ich immer
so einen Rat der Menschen verhelfen kann
auch wenn sie sich ärgern über falsche
politische Entscheidungen oder Personen
die ihnen nicht gefallen geht einfach
mal macht euch mal die Mühe diese
Gesellschaft zu vergleichen mit den
anderen Gesellschaften und dann überlegt
mal bitte möchte ihr wirklich in einer
Gesellschaft leben die von einem Putin
regiert wird oder auch von einem Erdogan
oder was auch immer wo ihr hingehen soll
von Iran und und China ja und wenn wir
uns die Mühe machen würden diesen
Vergleich wirklich in Ruhe vorzunehmen
dann würden wir plötzlich doch unsere
Demokratie noch erkennen als ein Raum
der Möglichkeiten trotz der
Erschütterung über die ich eben
ausführlich auch spreche es ist immer
noch ein Raum der möglich ist es und ich
sehe eben weltweit keine Angebote die
das überbieten würden und vor allem sehe
ich das ja nicht bei den
nationalpopulisten in Europa ich kann
auch über manches klagen was mir nicht
gefällt und und frage mich was wird die
künstliche Intelligenz noch mit uns
machen klar bin ich auch verunsichert
aber wenn ich mich dann umgucke und
schaue mir die
zukunftsprogramme an der
nationalpopulistischen Parteien ja was
ist denn da habe ich da irgendeinen
Grund zur Zuversicht eher nicht
Olaf Scholz sind sie die schlechte Laune
Partei naja
finden Sie diesen Begriff na er ist nur
zum Teil richtig es gibt diese Leute die
die schlechte Laune haben ich sag mal
wenn wir wir haben vorhin über die
Menschen im Osten Deutschlands
gesprochen da gibt es natürlich Leute
die früher zu den führungselierten
gehörten die die
beschlossen haben sie verbleiben im
Dauerfrost das ist eine Minderheit aber
die gibt es das sind Leute die
schlechten Laune machen die die
Demokratie immer runter reden werden
aber es gibt eine andere Gruppe und das
sind die die eigentlich ganz munter
waren als es darum ging die DDR-Diktatur
abzuschütteln die dann aber
überfordert waren in der Freiheit
ihren Raum und ihren Platz zu finden
auch weil sie vielleicht arbeitslos
wurden weil sie in einem unguten Alter
waren so wie meine Generation vielfach
zu alt für zum Erlernen der neuen Berufe
und zum Erfüllen der neuen Erwartungen
und da ist es aber ein fremdheitsgefühl
sie sind nicht vertraut genug mit diesem
Raum der Möglichkeiten der aber eines
von uns fordert dass wir vielleicht
selber aktiv werden und da ist es dann
es klingt paradox aber das ist dann ein
Trost wenn wir einer sagt du brauchst
gar nicht selber du ein der dir sagt wo
es langgeht und daher kommt diese
Neigung ein Führer haben so die wollen
doch nicht alle Adolf Hitler haben nein
aber sie wollen zum Teil von der Land
befreit sein
eigenverantwortlich zu sagen diese
Diktatur ist auch das was ich aus ihr
mache und da ist natürlich ein Anspruch
mit verbunden und dem fühlt sich nicht
jeder gewachsen und dann kommt diese
diese Griff raus ja ich habe ganz viele
Fragen gerade im Kopf die die sich
spontan gerade ergeben und weil es so
gut passt und äh die Analogie sozusagen
sich förmlich aufdrängt ihre
Abschiedsrede und dann noch mal kurz
reinhören dürfen
ganz bemerkenswert bitte schön
es ist das glaubte ich damals und das
glaube ich heute das beste dass
demokratischste Deutschland was wir
jemals hatten aber Demokratie ist kein
politisches Versandhaus
Demokratie ist Mitgestaltung am eigenen
Schicksal
ja ich dachte ich mir für es eben Herr
Friedmann klar eingefallen der gerade
davon gesprochen hat dass ich so eine
Haltung durchgesetzt hat die nennt der
konsumistisch das heißt der Bürger sagt
nicht mehr das ist hier mein Dorf mein
Land in meinen Staat hier letzte wird er
ist ja auch gewerkschaftmacher
vielleicht auch nicht so sondern dass
sie die sollen mal bringen Richard David
Precht mit dem ich mich häufig darüber
unterhalten Podcast sagt immer da ist so
eine Mentalität entstanden der Stadt als
Dienstleister des
Bürgermeister und er sagte aber und das
ist natürlich interessant Politik hat
die Menschen auch dahin erzogen ja hat
sie sozusagen
verwöhnt ist jetzt das falsche Wort aber
immer weiter mit der Gießkanne soziale
Wohltaten verteilt die irgendwann diese
Mentalität gefördert haben ich kann das
schwer beurteilen das müsste man
natürlich intensiver untersuchen ob
etwas dran ist aber diese Haltung ist
natürlich eine die man feststellt und es
ist auch genau das was dadurch kommt
wenn man sagt die oben und wir da unten
und die machen ja eh nichts für mich und
den reagieren die da oben mit Wohltaten
das was sie eben ansprechen ja dass mir
ganz lieb dass sie das Thema ansprechen
weil es nicht so ganz einfach also das
ist natürlich
so wie wir hier gestrickt sind mit
unserem Sozialstaatsmodell das ist ja im
Grunde auch in der Verfassung und die
Skandinavier haben sowas ähnliches das
heißt unsere Gesellschaften sind so
organisiert dass keiner unter Brücken
schlafen muss sondern da gibt es
Fürsorge und es gibt verschiedene Pakete
und Jungs in Krisen gab es wiederum sehr
massive Zuwendungen für Menschen die
schlecht gestellt sind und das alles
begrüßen wir mehrheitlich und auch die
anderen es gibt aber andere in den USA
wollen nämlich dieser was soll denn das
da depotenziert ihr Menschen ihr zwingt
Sie nicht sich selber für sich selber zu
sorgen sondern das ist etwas Paten
realistisch von oben herunter und ich
habe eine Zeit gehabt da habe ich das
auch gedacht man könnte eigentlich auch
mehr von den Leuten fordern also der
Herr Schröder von dem ich heute nicht
viel halte aber damals hat er so einen
Satz gesagt Fördern und Fordern und bei
vielen die so im linksliberalen Milieu
verortet sind ist fordern was Schlechtes
aber jeder der Kinder erzogen hat weiß
man tut Menschen nichts Böses wenn man
etwas von ihnen fordert und man tut
ihnen auch nichts Gutes wenn man nicht
Sie verwöhnen und deshalb ist im Grunde
der Verzicht darauf etwas von Menschen
zu erwarten eigentlich nicht besonders
menschenfreundlich aber wenn wir jetzt
unsere Gesellschaft mit dieser
Problematik vergleichen mit den USA dann
sehen wir doch dass wir etwas einen
Vorsprung haben weil die Gesellschaft
nicht aus sozialen Gründen derartig
auseinandergefallen ist wie in anderen
Teilen der Welt das heißt diese Fürsorge
die man für die manche von der manche
meinen sie sei übertrieben hat
gleichzeitig ein etwas heilenden Effekt
erhält die Gesellschaft mehr zusammen
jetzt wäre aber es wirklich wichtig dass
wir eben erkennen wir tun Menschen
nichts Böses wenn wir etwas von ihm
verlangen sie ertüchtigen ihn zu zeigen
welche Potenziale in ihnen stecken und
da genügt es nicht immer die Gießkanne
zu nehmen das das Gefühl ist natürlich
bei den Leuten tatsächlich ein anderes
also ich sag mal so es ist ja
interessant
dass der Einstieg in ihre
Präsidentschaft das Ende ihrer
Präsidentschaft auch das Thema heute
hier wir Kreisen immer wieder um
dieselben Themen das heißt offenbar
haben wir schon lange ein Thema mit
bestimmten Dingen offensichtlich gibt es
schon lange Probleme
Entwicklungen über die wir nicht
genügend reden die wir nicht versuchen
in den Griff zu kriegen und die war
einfach so vor sich hinlaufen lassen ich
sag mal so eines der gut gehüteten
Geheimnisse von Globalisierung ist
das längst auch die Mittelschicht unter
die Kinder kommt und ich habe das dieser
Tage gedacht als dieses heizungsgesetz
kam wie überrascht offensichtlich diese
Berliner Politik davon war dass auch die
gut verdienende Mittelschicht
Ärztinnen Leute die die Anwälte Menschen
die durchaus in der Lage sind ja etwas
zu stemmen das selbst die sagen sorry
tut mir leid das kann ich nicht so geht
das nicht ich kriege das nicht mehr auf
die Reihe bei der Inflation bei dem was
baumateriale mittlerweile Kosten bei dem
was die Dämmung eines Hauses kostet bei
dem was Handwerker Kosten mir wächst das
alles über den Kopf wie kann wie konnte
uns das passieren dass uns der der
richtige Blick auf der Realität der
Menschen so entgleitet ja das hängt viel
mit bunt denken zusammen ich habe ihn in
meinem neuen Buch über Wunsch in einem
anderen Zusammenhang mit dem Politik
viel gesprochen aber es gibt auch auf
anderen Gebieten und wenn du große
Absichten hast wie im Grunde das Klima
zu retten dann hast du einen so großes
Thema dass du denkst du musst jetzt
wirklich auch sonst was leisten um hier
ein eine fürchterlichen Entwicklung
etwas entgegenzusetzen und dann
verlieren sich auf die Maßstäbe ja was
ist verhältnismäßig was haben wir von
den Bürgern fordern und was nicht und
dann sind diejenigen die jetzt ganz den
ganz bewusst ist wie dramatisch die Lage
ist die sind mit ihren Erwartungen was
Menschen können sehr weit weg von dem
was Menschen tatsächlich Vermögen und
deshalb ist es so dass die einen zu viel
haben an Sehnsucht nach Wandel und
Erneuerung das erzeugt bei den anderen
eine andere Sehnsucht nämlich nach dem
Verbleiben im vertrauten und das ist
auch diese diese diese beiden Arten von
von Sehnsucht die in uns Menschen wohnen
spielt auch bei vielen anderen Themen
eine Rolle auf der einen Seite gehört es
zu uns nach frei zu sehen auf der
anderen Seite sehen wir uns genauso ist
soll aber nicht zu viel anders sein und
das ist wieder dieses politische Thema
mit der äußersten Rechten die
versprechen uns das bleibt alles so dass
wir uns nicht mehr Sorgen machen müssen
im eigenen Land heimatlos zu werden aber
beides gehört zu Menschen und wenn ich
jetzt eine fortschrittliche Politik
organisieren will dann brauche ich
gleichzeitig eine realistische
Einschätzung über das Potenzial an
Wandlung was den Menschen möglich ist
irgendwann sind Menschen überfordert so
und da ist zum Beispiel ein Punkt
schauen Sie ich mit so einer
christlichen Grundeinstellung würde
natürlich jederzeit sagen dies ist ein
Einwanderungsland und Menschen in Not
sind haben wir aufzunehmen und für die
haben wir uns zusammen gleichzeitig
musste ich als Präsidentin mir Gedanken
machen du kannst auch zu gutmütig werden
und dann kommt irgendwann der Präsident
in eine Zwangslage und haut dann einen
Satz raus unser Herz ist weit aber
unsere Möglichkeiten sind endlich dann
haben viele gute Präsident wieso sagst
du das so und jetzt kommt meine Antwort
ich musste dann lernen
du hast gute Absichten aber für diese
gute Absichten brauchst du gute
Mehrheiten und wenn es nicht möglich ist
für deine guten Absichten diese
Mehrheiten zu bekommen dann stimmt etwas
nicht so in in so halt auf dein mit
deiner Agenda total interessanter Punkt
der Satz den den den haben ganz ganz
viele im Ohr ist dann wirklich berühmter
Satz wir haben uns den noch mal
angesehen in der Vorbereitung auf die
Sendung und vielleicht spielen die
Kollegen aus der Regie dann einfach mal
zu und wir schauen mal unten rechts auf
das Datum wann ist dieser Satz gefallen
das ist aus heutiger Sicht fast noch
interessanter als die Tatsache dass der
Satz also gefallen ist wir hören mal
kurz rein
wischen trauen wir uns wenn nicht
sollten wir uns trauen das fundamentale
Dilemma dieser Tage offen auszusprechen
wir wollen helfen
aber unser Herz ist weit doch unsere
Möglichkeiten sie sind endlich
27 September
2015 in meiner Erinnerung nicht nur in
meiner ist dieser Satz sehr viel später
weil dann langsam klar wurde was das
bedeutet und wie irgendwann ein Land an
die Grenzen des machbar ankommt ihnen
war das offenbar schon im September 2015
in meinem Leben früher als ich noch
einen evangelischer Pastor war musste
ich nicht so über die politischen
Konsequenzen meiner Wünsche und Aussagen
nachdenken aber als Präsident musste das
Schauen und du musst dich fragen wie
willst du deinen human Ansatz
mehrheitsfähig machen und das geht nur
und das war für mich schwierig wir haben
lange in diesem Satz gefeiert damals
immer ich wollte aber dass wir in der
Mitte der Gesellschaft auch über Sorgen
und Probleme sprechen die mit
Zuwanderung verbunden sind und nicht
dass der Stammtisch oder rechts außen
die Probleme die ist und die politische
Klasse und der prä sozusagen nur
Vielfalt ist gewinnen wir wissen dass
Vielfalt gewinnen ist aber eben doch
nicht nur
von Problemen die wir zu bewältigen
haben aber warum ich meine 2015 ja jetzt
sitzen wir hier im Juli 2023 ja es ist
zu wenig passiert weil es hart acht
Jahre wissen Sie sie sehen doch wie soll
Frontex agieren
ist es vorstellbar dass Europa die
Flüchtlinge aus allen möglichen
Problemen zu und wirklich beherberlich
und integriert ja ist das möglich ich
habe bei uns im in seinem Buch zu werden
muss Problematik gelesen dass alleine
integrations alleine in auch selber mit
Migrationshintergrund ne ja ja mit sehr
vielen Material
allein zwei Länder habe ich so mir
gemerkt Nigeria und der Anna können sich
75 % runter Bevölkerung vorstellen
wegzugehen das sind aber relativ gut
organisierte Staaten in bisschen im
Kontinent viele andere Staaten sind sehr
viel desaströse aufgestellt wenn du
alleine die Problematik ich lasse mal
Syrien aus und andere Krisengebiete
Afghanistan wo Menschen zu uns kommen
und du kriegst mit ja du hast den
menschlichen impetons ich will helfen
und gleichzeitig musst du dir die Frage
stellen wie weit geht es und dann ist
die eine Regierung eher bereit als die
andere dann auch eine gewisse Härte zu
entwickeln oder so das können wir und
das können wir nicht wenn dies aber
ausbleibt meinetwegen aus
Menschenfreundlichkeit dann entsteht in
einem Teil der Bevölkerung der Eindruck
da gibt es ja eine Unsicherheit bei
unserer Regierung da ist etwas nicht
gestaltet und das erzeugt Ängste den
Handlungsprinzipien nicht erstens
erklärt und zweitens nicht beachtet
werden sondern man zuwartet dann
entsteht ein Vertrauensverlust und der
Bevölkerung
und wir wenn wir mal von Deutschland
wegschauen es ist mir wirklich wichtig
dass wir nicht nur über deutsche
Probleme sprechen diese musterländer von
Demokratie im Norden in Skandinavien die
die offensten Gesellschaften hatten die
wir aber hauptweltweit kennen sozial
ausgeglichen
primaordnung jeder Mensch möchte dort
gerne leben ausgerechnet in diesen
Gesellschaften haben wir starke
nationalistische Parteien und warum weil
dieses Problem der massiven Zuwanderung
in einer Weise unbearbeiteten von der
Politik dass die Leute dann nach rechts
außen gehen und das ist deshalb haben
die nicht nur gauland sondern viele
andere Führer der nationalpolistischen
Parteien für dieses einem juweliert ein
Geschenk hatte
das ist für die diese Einwanderung für
uns und sie stellen auch zusammen haben
sie sagen wenn man sich das anschaut
dass das korreliert also die Zahlen
gehen nach oben und die Zustimmung der
Witz ist jetzt wieder man also diese
Typen kommen bei uns nie an die Macht in
Deutschland aber man stelle sich vor Sie
würden sagen sie wird sie sich sicher ja
da bin ich mir sicher Deutschland ist
doppelt geimpft wir hatten eine braune
Diktatur eine rote und eine weitere
wollen wir nicht also wir bleiben bei
unserer gut das relativ gut
funktionierenden
liberalen Demokratie und wir sind nicht
Weimar dieses Land hat eine Demokratie
und genügend Demokraten weil immer hat
er eine Demokratie aber nicht genug
Demokraten also wir schaffen das die die
mit diesem Land sie sind sich da ganz
sicher total absolut weil die haben zu
wenig anzubieten ja die haben die haben
ein Programm für die Unzufriedenen für
die Heimatlosen für die die mit der
Moderne fremdeln und das ist auch normal
ich fremde manchmal auch mit der Moderne
ja also das ist nicht gleich schlimm
darf ich mal ganz ganz kurz also es gibt
ein paar in der Vorbereitung auf diese
Sendung wirklich sehr sehr interessant
das Institut wir reden jetzt über
Thüringen ja für Arbeitsmarkt und
berufsforschung erwartet das sind
Thüringen bis zum Jahre 2035 also auf
der Zunge zergehen lassen ungefähr
140.000 Jobs verloren gehen werden eine
Million Arbeitsplätze gibt es dort
140.000 werden mutmaßlich verloren gehen
warum weil sie nicht neu besetzt werden
können so und das kontrastiert so hart
mit dem afd-programm also wenn sie wenn
sich diesmal klar macht dann würde man
doch sagen da brauchst du jetzt eine
Partei die von Wirtschaft das versteht
die AFD steht gerade über 34% in
Thüringen hat einen Mann in ihren Reihen
Björn höcke von dem sie sagen tut mir
leid wenn ich das so hart sagen muss
aber der erinnert mich an Göbels so wie
er redet der spricht wir können uns
ähm man darf ihn juristisch auch
festgehalten einen Nazi an
rechtsradikalen nennen
diese Partei sagt wir wollen erstens den
Euro abschaffen für ein Land wie
Deutschland das so sehr darauf
angewiesen ist dass wir in diesen
Wirtschaftsraum funktionieren alle
Katastrophe dieses diese Partei sagt wir
ziehen im Zweifel die Grenzen wieder
hoch für ein Land das zu 50 Prozent das
ist unser Land von Export lebt
50%. unseres Wohlstandes kommen nur aus
dem Export wer sind wir dass wir daran
interessiert sein sollten
Schranken wieder hochzuziehen Mauern
hochzuziehen all das verfängt bei den
Leuten dann Klimapolitik wollen wir
beenden sagt die AFD wenn man sich mal
umschaut in der Wirtschaft ist ja
wirklich interessant die
Chemieunternehmen BASF geht nach China
nicht nur deswegen weil man dort gutes
Geschäft machen kann sondern auch
deswegen weil sie dort für das was sie
tun grüne Energie zur Verfügung gestellt
kriegen Daimler andere küssen arbeiten
gerade an grünem Wasserstoff massiv
nicht weil sie vielleicht unbedingt nur
so gute Menschen und Umweltschützer sind
sondern weil sie verstanden haben dass
ihre Kunden das in Zukunft nicht mehr
anders wollen die wollen in einem Auto
sitzen von dem sie wissen dass es
nachhaltig erzeugt worden ist und so
weiter und so weiter und eine Partei die
sagt pass auf lass uns wieder zurück zu
russischem Gas und so weiter der Putin
der macht das schon so also komplett in
die entgegengesetzte Richtung und
gleichzeitig bräuchtest du eine echte
Wirtschaftskompetenz und gleichzeitig
stehen über 34%. wie geht das zusammen
weil die Menschen nicht nur leben weil
sie denken sondern während sie leben
fühlen sie dauernd und wenn Ihnen das
Gefühl in ihnen das Gefühl übermächtig
wird dass sie im eigenen Land nicht mehr
richtig klarkommen dass sie fremd im
eigenen Land werden dass diese moderne
sie überfordern dann spielen die von
Ihnen genannten Argumente plötzlich
keine Rolle mehr sondern sie wollen
etwas anderes sie wollen abgeholt und
getröstet werden
und das Sonneberg ja jetzt voll
beschäftigt
die polnische Regierungs ist eine Partei
die wenn es um Zuwanderung und Ausländer
geht sich vor keinem Restaurant schreit
als eine sehr deswegen die
morgengesättigte Politik Ausländer und
die ganzen Gefahren der Thron allein im
letzten Jahr hat die Partei mit ihrem
gesamten ausländerfeindlichen Argumenten
und 137
000 Ausländer zuwandern lassen und warum
weil sie die Arbeitsplätze sonst nicht
besitzen konnten das heißt auf der einen
Seite sieht man dann wir müssen uns mit
Unternehmen unter Unternehmen gut
Stellen auf der anderen Seite will man
aber die Verlustängste eines Teils der
Gesellschaft politisch nutzen und
deshalb sind die Widersprüche die sie
hier gerade aufgelegt haben für jeden
der denkt und aus der Abwägung der
Argumente eine wahre Entscheidung
ableitet das Interessante ist aber für
jene Menschen die zu förderst danach
trachten wer gibt mir die Sicherheit
dass ich mich morgen noch in meinem
Thüringen an als Thüringer fühle ist das
so und deshalb ist auch meine Bitte
nicht nur immer auf die Ostdeutschen zu
gucken sondern diese Gefühle von
Fremdheit gegenüber einer moderne die zu
viel und zu schnell wandelt als eine
ganz enorme Herausforderung für
fortschrittliche Politik zu sehen es
geht zum Teil und wieder schaue ich eine
Skandinavien wir haben erlebt wie die
Partei die über viele Jahrzehnte ganz
gestalten war in Dänemark die
sozialdemokratische Parteien im letzten
Wahlkampf im Grunde Wahlhilfe genommen
hat aus der argumentationskiste von
rechts außen sie haben nämlich bezüglich
der zuwanderungsproblematik eine Härte
an den Tag gelegt die wir sonst von
keine demokratischen Partei kennen ja
ich habe nicht mal die AFD gegeben
einwanderungs
0 so und jetzt mehr das musst du dir
vorstellen dass bei uns in der SPD oder
bei den Grünen plötzlich sowas kommt und
wir sehen aber jetzt dass sich in dieser
Koalition auch in der Debatte jetzt mit
den anderen Europäern bei der Frage
müssten wir nicht was regeln plötzlich
jedenfalls ein Problembewusstsein
gewachsen ist ich bin doch nicht da dass
man sagen würde ja jetzt haben sie es
geschneit jetzt jetzt werden wir
Handlungsfähigkeit nachweisen aber das
Problem ist erkannt und wird eben
Europäer europaweit besprochen und
dieser dieses Element der
unentschlossenen Duldung von Zuständen
die eigentlich verändert werden müssen
das ist das was dann wieder Leute die
verunsichert sind in die Arme der
relativ einfachen Antworten haben ne ja
was du musst immer vorstellen weil sie
haben von Thüringen gesprochen den
Arbeitsplätzen du musst dir mal die
Sehnsucht viele Menschen die im Osten
wohnen das ist doch wieder so mehr
homogener sei Mal Deutscher im alten
Sinne sowie bei das in der DDR die
beschreiben das ja auch in ihrem Buch ja
total interessante zahl ich hoffe ich
habe Sie richtig im Kopf 93.000
Ausländer waren in der DDR und
Studierenden Menschen die kein
dauernhaftes
es war klar die gehen wieder nach Hause
das war der Plan und das so war das und
deshalb sind noch interessante Zahl auch
aus ihrem Buch wo sie sagen 1990 waren
in diesem Land ungefähr sieben Prozent
Ausländer
wenige Jahrzehnte später sind wir bei
22%. ja mehr sogar noch was nicht
schlimm ist aber einfach um klar zu
machen gigantische Veränderung gefunden
das macht sich Politik oft nicht klar
ist ein Stressfaktor jedenfalls für den
Teil der Bevölkerung und das sind in
Europa in den Staaten Europas rund
33%, die im Grunde die Bedürfnis haben
im vertrauten zu verbleiben und der
Sicherheit mehr zutrauen als der
Freiheit und den Wandel fürchten und
deshalb brauchen wir für diesen Teil der
Bevölkerung eine glaubwürdige
wertkonservative alternative das nützt
nicht dass die Linken immer lauter
werden und die Grünen immer grüne den
Teil der Bevölkerung kann man nur
erreichen indem man in eine
wertkonservative Politik vor Augen hält
die aber handlungsfähig ist und ihr Plus
in der Gesellschaft einbringt und Wert
konservatives denken braucht jede
Gesellschaft gerade eine Gesellschaft
die sich in einem forcierten Wandel
befinden immer fragen Blick auf die zehn
Minuten zum Beispiel gerade ist die CDU
gerade die beschreiben Angela Merkel
geht immer weiter in die Mitte und dann
tut sich da plötzlich diese rechte
Flanke ist die CDU gerade diese
konservative in einem guten Sinn
klassischen Sinne konservative Partei
offensichtlich gibt's ja eine große
Sehnsucht danach und offensichtlich wird
diese Sehnsucht nicht bedient ja sie ist
jedenfalls sie ist im Moment ganz
erkennbar auf der Suche ja und das ist
jetzt schauen wir auf die Union wir
konnten früher ein ähnliches Phänomen
auf der linken Seite sehen die SPD war
sie links genug nein einigen war sie
nicht links genug dann kam die
Abspaltung ja und dann kam die
Linkspartei und einige sagen dann ja
weil wir nicht links genug sind so und
bei Angela Merkel war es so ja ist
Merkel ein richtig Union das war doch
für ganz anders mit Franz Josef Strauß
oder dem Alfred Trecker das war noch
kernige konservative und die Merkel geht
in die Mitte das geht ja gar nicht ganz
ein Leiden bei den sehr konservativen
aber Merkel wusste genau in Deutschland
gewinnt man Wahlen in der Mitte so nur
jetzt ist natürlich deshalb was die
Forscher eine repräsentanzlücke nennen
und was die SPD damals erlebt hatte mit
der Abspaltung und für die ganzen
konservativen Parteien in Europa
ganz erkennbar gewesen dass die
traditionellen konservativen Parteien
diesen dieser Sorge und auch den Ängsten
ob das jetzt eingebildete oder reale
waren spielt keine Rolle aber die hatten
nicht mehr die angemessenen Antworten
darauf und da geht dann ein Teil der
Wählerschaft verloren und deshalb
brauchen wir in jedem europäischen Land
und auch bei uns in der Union Menschen
die wieder in dem
normalen unionsfehler oder konservativ
Wähler sagen du hast ja eine Partei die
versteht was dein Bedürfnis ist die
teilt deine Sorge dass der Wandel zu
forciert ist dass wir uns übernehmen und
deshalb haben wir die und die und die
Vorschläge jetzt aber es ist nicht
bitter dass wir dann direkt von
konservativ das ausfällt rübergehen zu
reaktionär ja das ist der das ist
passiert und und sie stellen z.B auf die
simple Frage wie viel Einwanderung
verträgt eigentlich eine Demokratie
sie stellen diese Frage ja und ich geben
sie auch eine Antwort darauf es gibt
genug wissenschaftliche Arbeiten darüber
wir haben ich ich nenne nur mal deinen
Namen einen habe ich schon genannt ist
es gibt einen anderen Niederländer
Treffer auch ein Professor der ich
glaube das sind alles Sozialdemokraten
denn aus Großbritannien da gibt es eine
Fülle an Material und wir sehen auch wir
haben praktische Beispiele wie die
einzelnen Oberbürgermeister z.B mit
einer starken Zuwanderung Klage gekommen
sind manchmal ging das mit der
Integration bei manchen es ist total
gescheitert weil die große Gruppen in so
Quartieren hatten wo die dann zwei drei
Jahre zusammen Mocken das ging nicht gut
also wir haben statistisches Material
genug eins ist klar
dieses Europa kann nicht die Probleme
einer unerlösten und unbefriedeten Welt
alleine lösen und deshalb werden wir
zweierlei tun wir werden nach wie vor zu
unseren Werten stehen und diejenigen die
asylberechtigt sind aufnehmen wir
sollten lernen und da sind wir dabei von
Kanada zu lernen die schafft man ist die
Zuwanderung die wir brauchen zu nehmen
und dann müssen wir auch Formen finden
sagen wir mal ein humanes zurückweisen
weil das soll ja nicht brutal sein aber
es soll doch zeigen Leute wir sind nicht
imstande alle auf